play which i think is well it's not a  good uh  yeah it's not good  for their chess development  maybe for young guys for me this has  been excellent like  how many draws i've had to offer in  bundesliga and completely lost positions  to  22 2300 like it's it hasn't been pretty  but yeah i hear your point  come on  there's nothing to do i think there's  some update in the game but  sometimes the thingy here doesn't  doesn't update the way we would like it  to  oh what happened here yeah hey  whoa they made it to the pond ending  yeah we were  just the one we thought was losing yes  whoa  born to d3 and king comes around  just when we thought nothing could  happen anymore he takes on f3  that's a brazen decision he has a lot of  time on the clock  yes that's also a rookie mistake  wow too quickly yeah